trois sénateurs français se sont rendus
en ukraine le 29 mai afin de rencontrer
le député d'opposition vadim rabinovitch
peu de temps après leur retour le 10
juin
la sénatrice centriste de l'orne
nathalie goulet a posé une question au
quai d'orsay sur les mouvements
néo-nazis en ukraine les parti néo-nazi
développe des activités de plus en plus
visible y compris au centre de kiev avec
des stands de tir des pratiques de
montage et de démontage de kalachnikovs
et des bureaux d'embrigadement de jeunes
dans des milices qui se revendique
clairement de l'idéologie nazie trouvant
ses activités extrêmement préoccupante
elle souhaite connaître la position du
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian sur ce sujet et quelles
mesures il compte prendre pour éviter la
contagion de cette idéologie mortifère
est en effet ces derniers mois des
groupuscules néonazis se sont manifestés
sur la voie publique ou lors
d'événements cette question vient en
écho au salut nazi fait part des
ukrainiens supporteurs de football
alliés pro petrov lors d'un match amical
algérie est pertinent de l'ukraine
contre l'irlande du nord le 3 juin ou
encore à la manifestation organisée le
28 avril dernier en l'honneur de la
division ss galicienne numéro 1 composée
de soldats du craignent un autre
rassemblement polémique celui de janvier
en l'honneur de stepan bandera durant la
seconde guerre mondiale ce chef de
l'armée insurrectionnelle ukrainienne
s'est allié aux nazis ces batailles ans
se sont rendus coupables de massacres de
dizaines de milliers de juifs de
polonais de soviétiques
le président iouchtchenko avait
participé à sa réhabilitation en le
nommant à titre posthume héros de
l'ukraine en 2010 les manoeuvres pour
renforcer le patriotisme ukrainien
effacer l'héritage soviétique se sont
traduits par de curieuses bévue
mémorielle le titre a finalement été
annulée en 2011 et le gouvernement
ukrainien a toutefois condamné le
rassemblement d'hommage la division ss
le ministère des affaires étrangères
d'ukraine condamne fermement toute
manifestation de glorification des
troupes de la waffen ss
nous vous rappelons que la propagande
des régimes totalitaires en particulier
l'origine nationale socialiste est
interdite en ukraine mais difficile de
ne pas s'égarer lorsqu'on n'a pas
réprimé les sympathies néonazis des
ultras ukrainien en vue de stigmatiser
un ennemi commun les russes ou les
sauver
sic ou encore par pur calcul
électoraliste
aujourd'hui les courants de
l'ultra-droite ukrainienne reste faible
peu suivie et divisé mais leur histoire
et leur influence reste plus que trouble
sloboda le parti d'opposition est née
sur les cendres du snp eu une formation
politique dont l'emblème était une ruse
nazis son ancien leader andrei par ou bi
s'est racheté aujourd'hui une conduite
il est devenu le président de
l'assemblée nationale sous le mandat de
volodymyr zelensky en tant que centriste
sa venue en france à l'époque pour une
rencontre avec françois de rugy en juin
2018 avait déclenché les protestations
de certains députés autres parties du
litre à droite corps national
émanation politique du régiment azoff ce
parti est composée de vétérans de ce
bataillon proches de la mouvance
néonazie et son leader andry bill est ce
qu'ils affichent des convictions
suprématiste dès le début du conflit
dans le dôme basse les affinités
électives du bataillon à sauf avait été
repéré par la presse anglo saxonne mais
cette controverse n'a finalement pas
fait grand bruit dans l'approbation
générale de la révolution de maidan et
aujourd'hui le défilé de la division
galicienne numéro un
l'indigné que l'allemagne israël il faut
croire que les bottes des néonazis de
l'est font moins de bruit que leurs
semblables de l'ouest et qu'elle
n'empêche pas non plus les autorités
ukrainiennes de dormir